[Music]  it's time for EP social study what the  stars are posting online did Miley Cyrus  and Liam Hemsworth to get married that's  what fans speculated after my leash ad  Billy Ray posted this cryptic photo of  miley in a white dress with the caption  I'm so happy you are happy et has  reached out to Miley and Liam's reps for  comments then there's Emily Ratajkowski  soaking up some rays the model showed  off her bikini bod in a skimpy white  swimsuit I feel my most comfortable and  my most beautiful when I'm fresh out of  the shower and you know my hair still  wet and you know you throw on a little  moisturizer and go outside but Jimmy  Fallon is enjoying the snow posting this  family photo from a ski trip in Utah  [Music]